[Music]
saving a dog from being euthanized
that's what one local animal rescue a
home first spot is trying to do but
recently there are ties with the animal
foundation were severed Madison
Kimbrough joins us from outside the
animal foundation with tonight's story
Sasha when I spoke to a home for spot
they told me that they're no longer able
to rescue animals from the animal
foundation and now that rescue wants
answers we hear everything that goes on
they try to keep everything a secret but
there's always somebody willing to stick
up for a dog and tell what's going on
inside the animal foundation Diana
England owner of the local rescue a home
for spot sharing with 8 news now the
issues her organization has had with the
animal foundation what once was a
partnership has now been broken as the
rescue is no longer able to rescue dogs
from their facility specifically dogs
that are up for euthanization like Chaz
who was found near Durango and Lone
Mountain last week here's a video of him
with animal control as he was taken away
Angie Swayze a volunteer for a home for
spot created this change.org petition
which has already reached almost a
thousand signatures to help save chas's
life they said that he was dangerous
that he was too dangerous to release to
anyone and that they are going to
humanely euthanize him despite the fact
that a home for spot has trainers and
they were willing to take on that
responsibility and the liability
everybody that interacted with him
before Animal Control got there and
everybody that's interacted with him
outside of animal control since then has
not had a negative experience with him
at all the animal foundation releasing
this statement to eight news now the
animal foundation has a responsibility
to the community not to release dogs
that have presented in multiple
instances to be dangerous this dog does
not meet the criteria for transfer based
on a behavior assessment as of now Chas
is still alive and remains at the animal
foundation but time for him is running
out reporting near Bonanza and Mojave
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now
now as for those severed ties with a
home first spot the animal foundation
added that the matter of this dog is
unrelated to their decision and their
partnership with the rescue they quote
expect our partners to treat our team of
staff and volunteers respectfully and
professionally and that expectation was
not met in this instance end quote now
you can keep up with this story as it
develops and all the rest of our local
reports by following us on Facebook